[Music]  you  [Music]  your heart is a muscular organ that  pumps blood containing the oxygen and  nutrients your body needs the pumping  sections of the heart are  the right atrium right ventricle  left atrium and left ventricle  in your heart oxygen-poor blood flows  from your body through large veins into  your right atrium  next your blood moves into your right  ventricle which contracts sending blood  out of the heart to pick up oxygen from  your lungs oxygen-rich blood moves out  of your lungs into your left atrium then  moves into your left ventricle finally  your left ventricle contracts sending  oxygen-rich blood out of your heart to  your body